good morning believe nation today's
message is good is the enemy of great
over to you JJ Watt I told you guys good
in handing me a great never be satisfied
with anything never be happy with just
good every single day you need to do
something to make yourself better than
everybody else and that's the only way
we're gonna improve we can't be
satisfied with just being good you can't
go to your workout every day and just go
through the motions and be happy with
what you're doing every single day we
need to be the best we can possibly be
when something is bad you're gonna
change it when you hate something you're
gonna change it if you look at your
business you look at your customers you
look at your product or a new service
you look at your clothes you look at
your relationships you look at your
phone you know if you hate something
that's bad it's going to force a change
but when something that's just good you
don't do anything about it how many
things are just good in your life how
many customers do you have that are just
good how many products and services do
you offer that are just good are you in
a relationship that's just good are you
reading books or watching videos that
are just good there's so many things in
our day to day lives that are just good
and you have to find the drive to make
them great if you want to go off and do
great things you need to have greatness
around you right you need to be in a
great relationship you need to have
great clothes you need to have a great
product and great service you need to
have a great team you need to have great
customers you need to build for
greatness and often the way to do that
is to find something within the good
that you hate that forces a change so
here's an example I was working on the
website for eternal dance salsa and it's
working the about page I had to update
Alex's position on the about page
because he went from being an instructor
to being the guy that I hired
run operations for the business and look
at the page and I'm updating his profile
now I was gonna be the top of the page
and the page itself was just good right
like how many pages on your website are
just good but I looked at his picture
and I hated it Alex
I hated your picture it was cold it
wasn't speaking to his true personality
it didn't bring out the smile that you
always see him in class it created a
wall between him and the people who are
looking at it and that this has to
change we need something great like
blowing a page sure but if he's named to
the first time the page has got to be
great and then changing his picture and
updating his bio made me have to change
it for everybody because I'll it's now
had a great one but everybody else
sucked below they were just good and so
changing the page based on Alex's
picture that I hated make me change
everything on that page to make it
better and so if you stick in the land
of good you're never gonna get great if
you find something that you hate it can
be the spark the let you move to
something great so the question that
today is what is just good right now in
your business or in your life what's
just good and it's not forcing you
enough to want to make a change to be
great going deep really curious to find
out leave in the comments below I will
join the discussion thank you guys so
much for watching have an amazing day
continue to believe and I'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot
a vinspresso
the TV go